inestabilidad política 50% de paro
juvenil y 5 elecciones en 10 años estas
son algunas de las cuestiones que
marcarán las elecciones de kosovo este
domingo los ciudadanos elegirán su nuevo
parlamento entre un total de 28 partidos
los sondeos auguran una holgada victoria
para el partido autodeterminación
liderado por albin kurti un
ultranacionalista de izquierda que ya
ganó las elecciones en 2019 pero su
gobierno tan solo duró 51 días tras una
moción de censura bajo el argumento de
mala gestión de la pandemia y la falta
de diálogo con serbia
[Aplausos]
queridos ciudadanos de la república de
kosovo después de diez días de una
increíble campaña electoral durante un
periodo inusual después de miles de
kilómetros recorridos y cientos de
reuniones ustedes en todos los rincones
de kosovo el momento de los cambios
nunca ha estado más cerca
cómo
el segundo mejor situado según las
encuestas es el partido democrático de
kosovo que ostentó el poder hasta la
victoria de autodeterminación el último
partido de gobierno la liga democrática
de kosovo podría quedar en tercera
posición muchos ciudadanos ven a estos
partidos como representantes de la vieja
política que llenó al país de corrupción
y sacó a kurt y del gobierno con
diversas manipulaciones
durante los últimos 20 años hasta ahora
los mecanismos para limpiar la
corrupción no han sido eficientes y
ahora ha llegado el momento de hacer una
limpieza adecuada aquellos partidos
políticos que no basen su programa en
hechos profesionalidad y sinceridad
perderán los primeros resultados
oficiales se esperan unas horas después
del cierre de las votaciones a las siete
de la tarde el ganador tendrá el difícil
reto de estabilizar el país más pobre de
los balcanes occidentales